انضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من الرياض
استشاري الطب النفسي والادمان الدكتور
احمد الشهري دكتور احمد حياك الله معك
دكتور خليني ابدا معك اول شيء من
سالفه او مساله زياده عدد كثافه التحضيرات
اللي شفناها خلال فتره الماضيه من ماده
الشيب والمخدر
السبب هل هو لزياده اعداد المتعاطيين ولا
العلاقه
التعاطي بجرائم سجلت ربما في الفتره
الاخيره انا اعتقد من وجهه نظري انه بسبب
الارتباط ماده الشبه بالجرائم وخصوصا
الجرائم ذات الطابع الانيف همم يكون فيه
همم طالع صادم حتى همم المجتمع همم بشكل
عام همم يعني الجرائم قد تكون يعني مصنفه
في تصنيفات معينه ولكن في جرائم معينه
مرتبطه تكون ذات طابع همم نساوي والاعلام
بشكل
هذه الجرائم تتناول بشكل كبير في وسائل
الامني ذلك تكون ملفته للانتاج الحالات
جدته ربما اللي قتل همم انتم في المركز
همم الان من خلال هل لديكم او احصائيات
باعداد المتعاطيين خلينا يجيكم
المتعاطيم بشكل يومي ولا بشكل اسبوعي هلا
لمستهم اي فرق بين متعاطي هذه الماده في
الفتره الاخيره مقارنه بسنوات ماضيه ما في
شك انه الفتره الماضيه همم يعني تقريبا
خلال ثلاث سنوات الماضيه في همم
بدايه ظهور حالات همم تعاطي الشباب وسابقا
همم لم تكن موجوده ليكون في تعاطي مواد
اخرى مثلا حشيش الكبتاجون همم
المنبهات بعض الافيونات ولكن الفتره
الاخيره بدا تظهر حالات تعاطي الشباب همم
طبعا لعده عوامل همم من فتره لاخرى غالبا
يكون ايضا تعاطي الشبوه مصاحب يتعاطي مواد
مواد اخرى همم يعني
من الغاء من النادر انه يكون بدايه
التعاطيبو من ناحيه يعني خبره سريريه
وكلينيكيه غالبا يكون في تعاطي سابق
المواد اخرى ثم بعد ذلك تطور الوضع لعوامل
اخرى لمحاوله التجربه موضوع الشباب واحنا
نعرف ان الشبوه بشكل عام شده او سرعه تعلق
او خواص الادمانيه عاليه مقارنه ببعض
الشخص همم
من اول جرعه ولكن في تصنيف المواد المخدره
بشكل همم في قوه همم قوه او خلينا نقول
ميزات ادمانيا للماده لها خصائص ادمانيه
او سرعه التعلق الشباب من اسرع المواد
اللي ممكن الشخص يتعلق او يده من عليها
مقارنه لبعض
المواد المخدره الاخرى ليس بالضروره من
اول مره ولكن بسرعه همم او بشكل اسرع من
بقيه المواد الاخرى لذلك همم تجد حتى
التركي بشكل عام في بعض المرات في وسائل
الاعلام لانه سرعه التداول او سرعه همم
الادمان بشكل عام مقارنه بالمواد الاخرى
هو اسرع لذلك اثره اسرع
شو اللي يحصل لي متعاطي
الشادو ما هي الفئه الاكثر ربما مشاهده
همم الفئه الحاليه غالبا يكونون المراهقين
وصغار السن يعني مرحله همم
ممكن نستطيع ان نقول من ال 14 الين همم ال
25 بشكل عام فغالبا هذه المرحله همم هم
اكثر من يكونون يعني همم
متعاطيين لماده الشباب اكثر من همم
المراحل العمريه همم الاخرى هذه من 14 25
في فرق بين
المتعاقين من الذكور والاناث طبعا همم ما
نقدر نقول انه في فرق لانه لا توجد لان
يعني دراسه واضحه وحتى لكن اكثر الحالات
اللي تجيء لكم همم
قابليه الذكور وضغط الاهالي بشكل عام لطلب
العلاج اكثر مع الذكور اكثر من البنات او
همم النساء بشكل عام
لتصل لكم الان وهل بالفعل انه هو الاخطر
هو الاعنى فعلى عقول همم المدمنين هو
الاقرب ارتكاب اجريمه نعم مثل ما ذكرت لك
خالد انه الشبو الشبو الشبو ااا يعني مثل
ملكات خصائص الكيميائيه همم وقدرته على
افراز المواد الكيميائيه بشكل قوي وبشكل
كبير
يعجل من سرعه الادمان ايضا تاثيره على
خلايا الدماغيه والتاثيرات السلوكيه
والنفسيه اعلى واسرع من باقي المواد
الاخرى لذلك نجد انه همم وجود الاعراض
السلوكيه العنيفه موضوع الاعراض الدهنيه
موضوع الاعراض
الشقوق الهلاوس ومن ثم بعد ذلك يتم ارتكاب
الجرائم بناء على هذه المؤثرات او هذه
التاثيرات همم المتعلقه بماده الشابو
خليني انتم لو تذكر لي قصه وردت لكم يمكن
خلال فتره الماضيه هل تذكر قصه معينه
مؤثره للدكتوره
همم القصص بشكل عام كثيره
وغالبا يعني انا خلال عملي اييه يعني ولا
الحمد يعني ما وصلني حاله مثلا جرائم قتل
ولكن اعتداء اعتداء على الامهات اعتداء
على الاباء موجود
بخصوصا يكون تحت تاثير الشبه همم في بعض
الاحيان حتى ممكن الاهالي همم ما يكون
عندهم علم او همم
اشتباه بحاله الادمان الا لما يصل لحاله
ارتكاب جريمه او بعد ياخذ وقت حتى يصل
للمرحله هذه الدكتوره ليس بالضروره هو
يعتمد لكل شخص له عوامل معينه مثل ما
ذكرتك كميه الاستخدام
وفتره الاستخدام لها لها علاقه
همم علاج متوفر وليس مستح همم ياخذ وقت
ياخد وقت
نعم هي رحله احنا دائما ومن هذا المنبر
نبين انه رحله همم علاج الادمان بشكل عام
هي رحله وليست يعني مرحله واحده فقط هي
رحله تبدا بتدرج وبعده مراحل معينه وفيها
همم مجاهده والتزام من المريض ومن عائله
همم المريض انا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على هذه
الافاده والمعلومات دكتور احمد الشهري
استشاري الطب النفسي شكرا لك شكرا لك